are you looking forward to the division
maybe you're waiting to pick up an xbox
one for the latest Tom Clancy game well
Microsoft has just the giveaway for you
as posted on major nelson's blog the
company has a 500 gigabyte xbox one up
for grabs and it's all decked out in the
division artwork the black and orange
design on the console looks pretty slick
as does the solid orange controller and
of course a digital copy of the game is
packed in to enter the giveaway all you
have to do is leave a comment on major
nelson's post and answer the question
what is your plan to take back New York
City from hostile factions tweets don't
count so you'll have to log in if you
want a chance to snag the custom console
there's only one xbox one up for grabs
but five runners-up will win digital
copies of the division you have until
the game launches at 3am eastern
standard time on Tuesday March 8th to
enter but considering there's over 3,000
comments already you should probably
move fast if you don't win you can
always pick up the division console
bundle and if you want to keep up with
all the latest news on the division
you're already in the right place